at least 30 people were killed and many
others injured Friday after a barrage of
Russian rockets and missiles targeted a
convoy of Civilian Vehicles heading to a
russian-controlled area of Ukraine to
visit relatives and bring supplies
yesterday a Russian President Vladimir
Putin declared that four regions of
Ukraine are now part of Russia following
sham referendums there the annexation
was widely denounced by the West
President Biden announced new sanctions
on Russia and more military aid for
Ukraine while Ukraine's leader president
zielinski is asking that his country
become a member of NATO Christina
raffini is at the White House with the
latest on this Christina good morning
good morning Jeff what we have is a tale
of two signing ceremonies the one you
mentioned with President Putin in Moscow
laying claim to those annexed
territories and another in key with
President zielinski where he said he's
submitting an emergency application to
join NATO something that at this point
is very unlikely to be granted now
unfortunately these two men are at this
point further apart than ever although
they've both said they're willing to
talk about peace Putin says he's not
going to talk about giving back any of
those annexed areas and zielinski says
he's only going to negotiate with
another Russian president at the White
House yesterday National Security
adviser Jake Sullivan called the
referendum vote a sham and so the U.S is
never going to recognize Russia's
claimed over those territories and
neither will the rest of the world
already we've seen widespread
condemnation from Western European ng-7
nations now when it comes to president
zlinski's NATO application look if you
remember that was one of Putin's red
lines for the invasion in the first
place it was part of the justification
he used claiming that NATO was trying to
expand in to Russian near Russian
territory so when you look at this
application NATO allies have been very
supportive of Ukraine both with weapons
and with rhetoric however they might not
want to take on Russia head on which
they would be treaty bound to do if they
admitted Ukraine into the alliance so
that's looking unlikely at this point
Dana
all right Christina raffini thank you
very much